we got the story from fox mcdonald's
drive-through customer spots
savage sign telling people to be patient
no one wants to work this is kind of
incredible to see someone at mcdonald's
actually put up
because it's uh it's their photo there's
there's a video of it i can't play the
video
well actually i think i can but i'd
rather just read it so it's a a tick
tock user named brittany logan spotted
the sign called it savage
it says we are short staffed please be
patient with the staff that did show up
no one wants to work anymore yeah
man the great elon musk quote if you
don't make stuff there's no stuff
yeah yeah but very diverse
simultaneously he supports ubi
sort of i've heard quotes all right
let's listen listen am i going to cry
about you know chemical garbage food not
being pumped out to the to to poor
people
not really it is a problem don't get me
wrong
but part of me deep inside is like i
just want to gloat that mcdonald's can't
you know keep cranking out this chemical
garbage food you know what i mean
yeah well i i certainly understand that
i also do wonder
how much of a factor is the
is you know the fact that people have
been really
i mean like the psychological damage
over the last
year is really something i mean pretty
much everybody in the positions of
authority in this country
we're just working overtime to
terrify the american people about this
floating abstraction of a germ
that they have to live their lives in
constant fear and always be inside and
covering your face and social distancing
and i'd imagine there are some people
that you mix that in with the economic
incentives of like
we'll pay you a little bit if you don't
work there's probably a lot of people
who are are like
really small that it reinforces the
belief yeah but i i don't i honestly
i don't know man i think it's probably a
lot of people being like don't gotta
work ain't gonna work
there's a lot of that too like look
before any coveted stuff we saw the
green new deal and what did it say
that that frequently asked questions put
up by uh aoc
they were willing or un unwilling to
work they said they were gonna provide
what does it say or economic access to
those unwilling to work
unwilling it's like your parents going
down to the basement and they see you
sitting there and your own filth and
like get a job
no shut up mom aoc is like we should
help him and give him money
the best part of it was that they put it
up on her website in the
in the frequently asked questions and
then when people started making fun of
it they were like
they were like offended that you'd bring
it up you're like oh you're gonna bring
up that old thing
it's from your website like what yes
we're going to ask you
about it so they said it was a first
draft right
was it supposed to go up there's a viral
meme where somebody tweeted it took a
viral tweet
this guy tweeted yo my job started
saying they were they're ending remote
working and people started quitting the
revolution is here
like there's actually a subreddit called
anti-work there are people who are like
i don't want to work
so the crazy thing is when you talk to a
lot of these leftists about this stuff
they say things like yeah but who would
want to work at mcdonald's you know like
is that a question of status or is that
a question of
money because you know i think a lot of
mcdonald's actually pay 15 bucks an hour
the problem is unemployment's paying
more than that
and so mcdonald's will have to increase
this is why ubi makes no sense
here's what here's what where this
ultimately ends up what's happening now
with this unemployment policy
is just eroding the base of the economy
which will ultimately fall apart ubi
doesn't work you know why you ever watch
the hunger games
you see the hunger games yeah and the
capital in the hunger games they
were gluttons who would drink ipac to
barf to eat more food
didn't like did they uh they did
something like that in rome didn't they
like vomitoriums or something after
feasting the feathers and stuff
it's not where the word vomiting is not
where vomitorium comes from but i that
might be true
something like that the point is in the
hunger games they have the districts
who have to work and you know the main
character is in the coal mining district
and the people in the capital don't do
work this is what these people truly
want
the leftists who are advocating for this
stuff want to live in the hunger games
but they want to be the capital
another example is how they want student
loan forgiveness
now i actually am for some form of
forgiveness maybe
forgiving interest rates yeah saying pay
back the principle of what you owe now
but we're not going to keep
raising the interest rates because
that's insane make it easy to pay off
but not free
how insane is it that the left right now
is advocating
for the working-class people to pay off
the debts of the highest income earners
in the country
college people with college degrees have
higher salaries than than people who
don't
and they want the working-class people
to pay
off their debts that is the capital city
in the hunger games
now they're saying these these memes
where it's like if you can't afford to
pay someone more than they could make on
unemployment
then you are exploiting poverty bro
they're paying people 16
an hour to be unemployment like how much
like how long is that going on
so it's been going on for a year and
then buying sync is gonna extend it okay
so the plan right now is with the new
two trillion dollar relief package is to
keep it going obama did that two
thousand eight nine something like that
but that was that was that was a
and i think that was an extension on
standard unemployment yeah
yeah it was an extension to 99 weeks
back then
um but the the thing is like you you see
biden talking about just the other day
when he gave that speech
to the distanced masked congress uh and
he's talking about
uh taxing corporations and how they
don't pay their fair share
and they have all these tax loopholes
and all this and they even forget the
fact that joe biden's been a senator for
85 years and he's written all of these
you know tax loopholes into the law or
at least sign them into the law
that the truth is that he just signed
one of the biggest
if not the biggest corporate welfare
bills in history and to sign that into
history and be giving all of these money
to giant corporations
and then turn around and say ah you know
we really got to get some of this money
back
is just so disingenuous i mean like like
stop giving them money stop taxing and
this is the same thing you're saying
with bailing out student loan debts
stop taxing working people and
paying the well to do with the money
that you got
if we can't get that basic thing right
what are we talking about this is out
here this is why democrats want 16 year
olds to vote
because 16 year olds are going to be
sitting there and being like yeah dude
it's like so dumb that there are
homeless people like
we have houses just put the homeless
person in the house like are you dumb
and that's what they'll be voting for
right now you have these
20-something democratic socialist types
who are like the body administration
needs to be printing money and
increasing unemployment this is absurd
people are losing their jobs it's like
have you ever had a job well no but
that's not the point
and then it's like okay so what you're
saying is the government
should borrow tons of money print tons
of money devaluing the savings of the
working class
while all the businesses are shut down
so that people are forced to buy from
amazon
so basically they're devaluing the money
you have and then
giving what they they've extracted from
you to amazon and walmart as they're
coming
that's great that's a great leftist
policy hey don't get me wrong these are
the people that are coming out right now
cheering for facebook and laughing about
it
that is until they get censored and they
come begging for help saying please
we're the free speech warriors i got
censored
so how many states are open
um i i think for the most part like the
blue ones are
like somewhat opening so now it's
basically like
sort of a battle of the states in a
sense
oh dude we're we are uh we're being torn
reds
you look at i think i mentioned this a
while ago joe biden said
you know we're gonna have another
lockdown if we need it and i'm like
florida's already open for business
so who's joe biden talking to only the
blue states
yeah when he comes out and says you know
do x do y
lock things down and texas is like doing
the exact opposite you know he is not
speaking to a single person in texas
yeah
i've never seen anything like this in my
life uh
in our country and there's been you know
there's always examples of where like
the media has their propaganda and
real people don't really believe it but
there's something about
watching you know um the you know fouchy
and the cdc guidelines and you'll see on
cnn and they're like hey we've
just decided you can take your mask off
outside and you're literally like
looking out your window at kids just
playing with their masks off and
it really feels like something out of
the soviet union like the the
propaganda has come down from pravda and
you're looking and you're like
we've been doing this forever but what
are you talking about
and i know there are some people who
haven't i don't know what i mean like
local ordinances have already ended on
outdoor maps but that's my point
i mean who like even of liberal people
who kind of believe in the whole like
we're supposed to wear masks thing
who has been following all of the rules
since
are people still living like it's march
of 2020 we're not
well what i'm saying is they actually
lifted the mandates in maryland for
instance
and then fauci's coming out later and
i'm like they already lifted the minutes
what are you talking about well that's
it and it's almost like they're going
like now we've given you our official
national orders that you can do the
thing
that you've been doing for 10 months but
so go ahead and do
and it's very bizarre and and and you
see this
right like in florida in texas people
which both states people are flooding
into
people have been living relatively
normal lives and and to pretend that
we're
just now getting to the point where
outdoors you can take your mask off
is really there's such a disconnect i
don't i don't think south dakota i've
ever even had that
yeah outdoor mass mandates i'm not i
don't think so uh taxes in florida
completely opened up
but i bring up maryland specifically
because it's like they got a republican
governor but it is a blue blue state
they lifted their outdoor mass mandates
a little while ago and now i see like
fauci coming out i'm like
who is he talking to california in new
york he's not talking to the rest of the
country so isn't this the tenth
amendment
in practice like okay from the example
of maryland i've never seen people
outside with masks period except the
occasional moronic runner who decides to
wear his mascara while he's running
but isn't this the 10th amendment where
states are just deciding to do their own
thing because this was never delegated
to the federal government
well you know this is i mean it's a real
sick perversion of the 10th amendment if
it is that
because truthfully none of the states
have the right to do what they've done
i mean they don't have the 10th
amendment basically says that
anything that is not expressly delegated
to the federal government
is left to the states or the people so
that if something isn't
uh you know delegated to to a federal
power the states can do it
but there is no uh legality to the
states
violating constitutionally protected
rights in the bill of rights so like
there the uh cuomo and
you know newsom and all of these
governors yeah
they did not have the right to shut down
a religious ceremony to
tell you that you can't peacefully
assemble i mean they what we've
dealt with over the last year has been a
true
rise of many dictators amongst governors
who have taken power to themselves that
should be
crushed by the federal or local
governments or anyone willing to do it
and to me this was the great failure of
donald trump
2020 that he did not do anything to to
listen i mean if there's if if some uh
one
diner in alabama somewhere
put a whites only sign outside their
door and the state government didn't
want to do anything about it
the feds would come in there and say no
you cannot do that you don't have the
right to do that
and okay fine but the
cuomo and and you know newsom can just
shut down their entire states
and nobody's going to come in and tell
them like sorry this is a free country
we have constitutionally protected
rights the the fact that that didn't
happen from anyone is
is uh unconscious when there were
lawsuits
against the state for doing it cuomo
went okay i'll make another executive
order and then sue me for that one
yeah and they just kept doing it that's
right you know so
you mentioned donald trump and he didn't
he he didn't handle this
and you know uh let me slow down a
second a lot of people talk about the
response to kovitz specifically having
to deal with the spread
and they say trump didn't do a good
enough job and i say well let's be
honest
there's no control group by which to
measure whether he did or didn't do a
good job you can argue that
some some things in your opinion may
have been better honestly i don't know
all that much
so i think operation warp speed must
have been a good thing a lot of people
are really excited cheering on joe biden
for the vaccines that
donald trump helped make happen but
donald trump did not use the power of
the federal government
to protect people's constitutional
rights for a year
and you know what what did we see as
riots
up across the country did donald trump
do anything about it no and people were
like
well hindsight is 2020 you know now that
we know that he lost
people are saying at the time yeah but
they'll call him a fascist say here it
comes and then you know he's trying to
win in november like well he lost anyway
so he didn't stop any of the extremists
they went around burning things down and
and smashing stuff and then we're all
left holding the bag with the biden
presidency who
also is doing nothing and it's only
getting worse thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you